[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
75 years ago that was a global
solidarity to annihilate the scourge of
fascism from Europe the Soviet Union and
its Western Allies prevailed against
Nazi Germany today such global
solidarity is sadly missing in face of
the current pandemic who in what bloc's
is very necessary solidarity I'll stop
this and more I'm joined by my
guesstimate by Babbage in Moscow he is a
political analyst and editor it enos me
internet project and in Cork we have
Jeffrey Roberts he is an emeritus
professor of history at University
College Cork and a member of the Royal
Irish Academy his latest book is
churchill installing comrades-in-arms
during the Second World War
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump any time
you want and I always appreciate it
alright let me first go to Dima here in
Moscow
you know Dima here we go again this is
almost like our tradition with our
colleague Jeffrey we do this every
single year commemorating Victory in
Europe over fascism and for every single
year that we do it we find ourselves
more and more in a revisionist mode here
I mean as I understand as we're sitting
down doing our chat right now is that
Facebook has banned a colorized version
of the of the Soviet banner over Europe
of the very very iconic one of showing
victory in Europe and you know I've
searched around it's a true story
I mean what in the world is going on
here the black-and-white version seems
to be acceptable the color would not are
there different meanings is this a
revision itself and why in the world
would anyone want to deny that iconic
photograph it's like the sailor kissing
the young lady on Times Square in
victory over Japan I mean what is going
on here go ahead do well I don't know
which exactly which flag exactly we mean
here most likely it's the iconic image
of a Soviet soldier Putin
the red banner over right star which was
basically the center of power the
official center of power in Nazi Germany
so for decades there was no problem with
this lab you know for Russians it's a
familiar image it's like the image of
American soldiers would have a flag in
the Pacific during the war with Japan he
would eat we're going to cause a scandal
here well basically a lot of Russians
are now thinking what's going on why
that is happening robert show everybody
here this is exactly the photograph were
talking he has the props even for the
program he had no idea what's gonna ask
this question we Russians were thinking
why it is happening Russia now is
certainly a better country for the west
and the Soviet Union ever wars we are
not hostile we have a pluralistic
attitude to history you know right now
in Russia you can hear and you can read
any kind of stuff about they won't go to
from an apple bound - you know Stalinist
revisionist you can get everything and
that makes us different from the West
now we're just one narrative seems to be
prevalent in the last few years and my
explanation is that the problem is with
the new Western ideology because it's
impossible that the same sad story would
suddenly happen in separate independent
countries that you would have the statue
for marshal Konev removed from Prague
and the Czechs say it was just the local
authorities who decided to do it you
know then you have you know Facebook
removing this photo the colorized
version of this photo Facebook is based
in the United States then it's not only
against Russia the name of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt was removed from every
in Poland unless people heard about them
and FD Roosevelt is still a national
hero in the night
that's diamond this is Jeff you know the
thing is is he right it seems to me and
I think they miss on to something it is
an ideological approach small this but
we can't
it's simply ludicrous to deny the
existence of historical figures now the
difference is is to glorify them okay I
get that all right but you know it's
almost like the iconic picture of Yalta
where you have you know Stalin Churchill
and Roosevelt and you know an ally in
them in this post Cold War environment
you know somehow that is sacrilegious
because you're putting Stalin on stage
here hang on here let me go to the point
is here is that history is something we
should learn from I mean it's just not a
moral play in the present go ahead Jeff
first ones might there's nothing good
about this historical revisionism
because a long way back I mean almost as
soon as the war has ended its history
was being revised for political
illogical illogical reasons so there's
nothing new about honestly the present
time it's it we're in a particularly
intense period of historical revisions
and as you call it and that's obviously
connected with the current state of
Russia's relations with the West and all
of that kind of thing notice I actually
agree with one points that mm8 which I'm
very much agreement you know Russia
these days you can say anything you like
about the war even you can actually put
forth any kind of extreme revisionist
fears anything at all it's actually much
more freely bait
about the war in Russia than there is in
the West but having said that you know
there's more than one narrative in the
West I think we shouldn't exaggerate
the power-on influence at the Western
liberal media and Western liberal and
police'
we shouldn't underestimate to the extent
to which among popular consciousness
there's quite a reasonable degree of
awareness of what the true facts of the
war
and in particular what to throw the song
eating played in a Red Army play in
defeating okay Jeff and then why are
these it seems to me the therapy for the
for the majority of people the majority
of media there's a new revisionist
narrative being pushed here but at the
same time you're saying that among the
population there's a level of awareness
I think that's true but I think it's
getting smaller and smaller I used to
teach at the University of California
and you know young they're supposed to
be the cream of the crop and their
knowledge was very scant and I have to
worry that it's even worse now because
we have Saving Private Ryan
you know we had I think yesterday the
White House really giving credit to the
United States in the UK for victory over
the Nazis now obviously not mentioning
the Soviet Union in one house the
question is that intentional or is it
just lack of knowledge to finish up on
that point Jeff go ahead why if there
were some countries country no I think
the United States is a pretty bad case
of a robber and narrow perspective on on
the history of war
yeah I mean this historical religious
narrative I mean it rose originally to
discredit communism communism and Nazism
totalitarian all this current kind of
thing nowadays of course it's political
functions to discredit Russia to
discredit Putin and to create a contrast
between Western democracy and rational
Thorat Arianism through a so you know
guilt by association of Russia with the
Soviet Union we need to totalitarian
posture so that that's what's going on
as one kind of question is let's not
give power to this kind of narrative by
exaggerating yas'm palmas that's
recognized account occurrence are out
there let's actually be part of the
context yes that's what I'm saying
well I mean Dima I mean you've known me
for a very very long time and that's
always been my gripe is that it's very
difficult to talk about anything related
to Russia because it's always about
context and if you don't have basic
facts then you don't have any context
okay and that's the difficulty in
discussing all this I mean you know
there
different narratives about the the war
and victory as a result of that war
I mean I've always taken the position is
that most of the soldiers that died
didn't die for communism they died for
Mother Russia they died to protect their
families their tradition their language
their civilization the idea ideological
spun you can put a spin there but you
can put it there but I don't think
that's the majority of the opinion of
the people that fought there my opinion
go ahead Dima
well I think people died for a variety
of reasons
you know defending Russia and defending
the Soviet Union it was not only
Russians but I think the main reason was
survival you know they people realized
that if he wins we're not going to
survive and what happened later was that
when Khrushchev came to power he thought
Stalinism by Stalinist means I mean the
problem of the character of style then
is the following basically a crucial
removed stallion from all the narrative
about the war in the same way as started
removed Ryan or Trotsky from the
narrative about the 1917 revolution so
what happened under Putin was now
freedom team now you can be a Stalinist
you can say that you think starting you
know was very important and he won't at
war you can be an anti sturdiness and
the majority of if you watch Russian
dead when there's a lot of movies about
the war he made now and each of them
mentions repressions so when in the West
they say oh Stalin has been
rehabilitated Putin is bring up starting
back there is such a big lie because you
know the way Khrushchev and Brezhnev for
stallions was studies you know I was
born in 1970 I remember that I first saw
Stallions picture when I was 13 in 1983
on the windshield of a car you know that
was wrong you know whatever we think
about style
as a figure it was wrong to remove his
image to remove all memory about him and
now the West wants us to repeat the same
thing you know to demonize that person
and I'm returning to this ideological
thing I pull the the modern age of the
West I quote it out to liberals I
wouldn't even call it Western ideology
why because it's not in the Western
tradition it's very if you want anti
Shakespearean you know Shakespeare has
dimensional characters and the problem
with the modern Western narrative is
that it does not allow dimensional
characters enter its narrative starting
was at the same time a dictator that's
true and the victor in this war
it was his nerve it was his willpower it
was his ability to I would say that the
Soviet Union won the war in spite of
style and okay but see we're just
demonstrating to our viewers that there
is a debate here I see Jeff laughing in
my book stars wars in which arguing yes
darling was a brutal dictator but he was
also the single most important person in
terms of winning the second world war as
I put in my book you know sobbing you
know stone inside the world for Western
Western democracy humane point by the
way to contest this historical
revisionism is with not by producing a
controller eyes political and logical
alternative to narrative the way to
contest it is with historical truth when
we get to historical truth about
complexity contradiction all kinds of
stuff going on you might not might not
like so yeah we have to talk about the
other Soviet victory in the Second World
War but we also have to talk about the
nazi-soviet subsonic back what we're
gonna do after the break we're gonna go
to a
or breaking after that short break we'll
continue our discussion on remembering
Victory in Europe 75 years ago state
with aren't you welcome at the cross
stock where all things are considered on
Peter LaBelle Tremonti we're talking
about victory over fascism in Europe 75
years ago
[Music]
okay let's go back to Deema here in
Moscow here right before we went to the
break Jeffrey brought up the nazi-soviet
pact of course this is hotly debated
today and with good reason I would say
because it kind of flushes out the
historical facts that Jeff was getting
to before we went to that break you know
maybe you and I have talked about this
so many times here and and as you
pointed out to me very eloquently yes
that pact that exists and there were
secret protocols we know that as part of
a historical record but the way it's
being framed right now is that there's
something the Soviet Union is culpable
in a unique way because of that
agreement but that isn't so most
countries in the in Europe had some kind
of security agreement treaty with Nazi
Germany before hostilities broke out in
September 1939 you know where I'm going
with this go ahead Deema oh well you are
absolutely right and when the patriarch
of the Russian Orthodox Church recently
saved said that this war was the
punishment was since a lot of people
were angry at him they said how come you
know all these millions of people were
sinful
well no but diplomats diplomats
representing these countries yes because
basically every country in Europe with
the exception maybe of Czechoslovakia in
some way look what happened the check
was about here yeah somebody cooperated
with Hitler between 1933 and the 1941 so
it's a huge moral story if you want how
you don't create with evil without huge
consequences for yourself but again you
know this teacher luckily we don't have
picture of stallion heat or shaken hands
you know we have stallion and Ribbentrop
and that is reproduced now in billions
and billions of copies but we have this
picture of Churchill Roosevelt and
Stalin you mentioned it well I am very
concerned about this picture because the
Western ideology will either resent that
crime evidence because you know here is
loose loot and Churchill sitting next to
that villain you know or they were
simply prohibited because that will not
shoot a bear nurture you know the
problem with radical ideologies and the
West now has a radical ideology is that
they twist the past for their political
interests today they remove I thought so
that's what the Soviets did with history
the the future is certain but the past
is not exactly a lot of things that we
are now saying of thought crimes in the
West now there is no such thing as a
thought crime in Russia but there are
more and more kinds of thought crimes in
the West and the problem is that this
new Western ideology this outer
liberalism Cornell liver isn't what
having forward it operates by images by
hollywoodian
images you know Stalin is the villain so
that means that he is to blame for the
war Stalin Hitler to blame for the war
to megalomaniacs I have been reading it
in thousands of books now and people
seem to disregard that the war would not
have been possible without millions of
people prepare and walk all that would
willingly so the problem is much bigger
than just two megalomaniacs but this is
the way a modern Western ideology
removes its enemies they always find a
leader whom they demonize you know ASSA
or saddam hussein you know happening
they say you know we murder him
face it okay they don't say mother we
remove him and then everything will be
fine so they they try to apply the same
kind to old narrative to world war two
which was a very complicated story a
very complicated event but that's why
I'm concerned about this picture of
Stallion result and Churchill it shows
that basically people very different
beliefs would come to an agreement and
fight one big evil production we have a
demek we have different leaders and
different political systems different
world views but this pandemic doesn't
care what your politics are but we can't
have global solidarity internationalism
because globalism is it doesn't go far
well I keep plugging my books on this
which is 30 years ago was called the
unholy alliance stolen all right demons
right when you say everyone did business
with an Isis in the 1990s including some
very light sort sordid business such as
you know Munich and the dismemberment of
Czech Jack's market and nevertheless
there is something that was unique about
the Nazis thought that there's no
equivalent to that packed and it's any
secret protocol and he did have some
rather radical consequences and then get
getting away from it you know including
Red Army's invasion of Poland eastern
Poland in September 9th oh no no ok you
can say that the territories that were
taken over by the Red Army weren't
really Polish territories they were
western better Russia Western Ukraine
the United to route to republics so
there's certainly a case to be made in
defensive the Nazis the Nazis were
packed onions and it's a very
complication of historical events which
unfolds as a result of the pact leaning
into the devotion I don't think you need
a defense I say I wouldn't I wouldn't
phrase it the way a defense of it what I
would say is if there's a reasonable
explanation to understand why a bad
thing happened because look at Munich
you have the Western powers
basically destroying the post-world War
one international system unilaterally
destroying a sovereign state which they
had implicitly and explicitly said that
they would defend and then you go all
the way up to August 1939 and you get a
more egregious form of it the precedent
is set it used to degree I mean that's
why I really get sick and tired of
people
Aurel izing about an international
system that the Western powers had
corrupted before the two Outsiders Nazi
Germany and the Soviet Union were
involved in it okay the seats go way
back you know and then again I want to
make sure I don't think you'd have to
defend it you have to understand it go
ahead very like yeah that's a very
reasonable I'm actually quite a simple
explanation well an RC solid fact is
this is that throughout the 90 versus
the song euni including Starling sought
to create some kind of you know
anti-hitler coalition so I've got grand
alliance against fascism they failed
they fail because of Weston beastmen and
in the face of that failure Starling
turns is very dirty to this real project
at least you can describe as being an
amoral from solid brain size body it was
the only thing it was young the
alternative no fees for return that's
why they did that they were various kind
of actions which we receive it carries
appointees as you can the West can't
moralize over that when itself was a
copper ball for the destruction and I
would say the precursor to welcome then
become an inevitable war I mean the
remarkable thing if you look at the
historical record is that Hitler was
basically shocked that the Chamberlain
would agree to breaking up you know
breaking up parts of checkol same use of
these people who look at they're they're
really gonna sell them out I mean and
then months later the entire country was
occupied I mean if you want to use well
this is the okay so the Nazi so packed
is there well also as important more
important actually historical sense was
the grand alliance
yeah the world war two grand alliance
you know the big free rural attraction
and stuff so you know it worked and it
worked
go ahead demon it worked it's the most
successful exactly Arts in history is
huge
Connors it says Deema jump in well first
since we are working in paradoxes here
and
Jeffrey has just said that in a way
defeating Hitler
studying saved Western democracies in
the same way this pact first without it
I don't think that the collapse of the
Soviet Union in 1991 would be possible
because because of the pact the Soviet
Union has got Baltic States and Western
Ukraine inside itself these very hostile
entities you know which rebelled under
Gorbachev basically in the late ages as
soon as they had an opportunity to
express this themselves the immediately
turned against Moscow then if the West
doesn't like that pact so much they
should return Vilnius to point and then
this way I don't know how this game
would be without news but let me take a
very provocative look at that you know
you who can make parallels with the fact
in a lot of ways you know you can say
that now Russia and the United States
and the West in general cannot agree on
fighting coronavirus in the same way
they couldn't agree in 1939 on fighting
Hitler
despite his occupation of Austria
Czechoslovakia his obvious anti-semitism
but why did that happen well because the
United States and the UK they viewed the
solitude weariness negativity well now
the United States and the UK are view in
Russia and China very net they don't
want aid from China aid from China makes
them angry you know it's you know
they're talking about propaganda
and if later
Churchill stone can get together no why
can't contemporary politicians get
together directly confront this
particular crisis we're facing now the
answer that they can if they want this a
matter of political choice
manner of political calculation I may
have seen what what the important we
want the important interests are mean
the difference that is the difference
between then and now is it
then you had people that had courage you
had people that had some for and you
know even Stalin I would say okay I mean
he if you look at the Soviet ideology
dealing with the bourgeois West and you
know because the world was absolutely
shocked when the and the announcement of
the nazi-soviet the agreement was made
public I mean because after decades of
demonizing capitalism and all that
Stalin had to flip on a dime and say for
our survival we're gonna have to work
with these two characters you know
Roosevelt an install result in Churchill
here I mean the point is is that there's
vision okay there's no vision today
these people are walking around like
blind cats go ahead team in the last 20
seconds go to you well I think the
reason or why we do not agree now with
the West is precisely the same ideology
and let me make a provocative statement
in 1939-1940 right before the Hitler's
invasion of the Soviet Union more what
of prohibited to talk about national
socialism of the negative sense we
didn't talk about not ism as an ideology
and that made Rush those defenseless
when the Germans actually attacked in
the same way now we don't want to
believe in a new aggressive Western
ideology that's a mistake
it would be nice if it hadn't been there
but it is there that's a very good point
gentlemen we've run out of time I want
to thank my guest mass here in Moscow
and in court and I think I want to thank
our viewers for watching us here in RT
see you next time remember rules
[Music]